russia deploys troops to eastern ukraine
after recognizing the independence of
breakaway territories vladimir putin
also questioning ukraine's statehood is
it a prelude to a wider-armed conflict
and what impact will western sanctions
have
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan russian president vladimir putin
has sent troops into ukraine that came
after he recognized the independence of
two self-declared republics in breakaway
regions western countries have accused
moscow of taking a step towards a
full-blown invasion they've begun the
process of imposing sanctions putin
questioned ukraine's right to
sovereignty and said russian troops will
be there for peacekeeping purposes
i consider it necessary to make a long
overdue decision to immediately
recognize the independence and
sovereignty of the donetsk people's
republic and the luhans people's
republic i asked the federal assembly of
the russian federation to support this
decision and then to ratify the treaty
of friendship and mutual assistance with
both republics
it is also essential to understand that
ukraine has never had a tradition for
genuine statehood and since 1991 it has
taken the path of mechanical copying of
foreign models torn off both from
history and from ukrainian realities
political and state institutions were
constantly reshaped to suit the rapidly
formed clans with their selfish
interests that had nothing to do with
the interests of the people of ukraine
the whole point of the so-called
pro-western centralized choice of
ukraine's oligarch power was and is not
to create the well-being of the people
but to obsequiously provide services to
russia's geopolitical rivals for saving
billions of dollars stolen from
ukrainians and hidden by oligarchs in a
western bank account
[Music]
and right after the announcement the
western world began reacting u.s
president joe biden made a statement
through twitter saying i have signed an
executive order to deny russia the
chance to profit from its blatant
violations of international law
we are continuing to closely consult
with allies and partners including
ukraine on next steps
a lot of western leaders also warn putin
against annexation after his
announcement
if there is annexation it will be
sanctions
and if there is a recognition
i will put the census on the table
and the ministers will decide
keep in mind which is the process
of sanctions
according with the treaty sanctions are
being approved by the foreign affairs
minister's council
by unanimity
uh this is plainly in breach of
international law
it's a violation of a
flagrant violation of the sovereignty
and integrity of the
uh of ukraine uh
it is a repudiation
of the of the minx process and the minsk
agreements
and
i think it's a very
ill omen and a very dark sign
and it certainly does not seem to me
that it's it's certainly
an indication uh yet another indication
uh that things are moving in the wrong
direction in ukraine the uk will
continue to do everything we can to
stand by the people of of ukraine
with a very robust package of sanctions
as you know
what i can tell you
uh
and reiterate our position which that
the united nations fully supports the
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders as
stated very clearly in relevant general
assembly uh
resolutions and again we would encourage
everyone uh
involved uh
to refrain from any
unilateral decision or unilateral action
uh
that could undermine the territorial
integrity of uh
of ukraine and and the implementation of
the minsk uh
agreements i think is endorsed by the
security council and uh
with regards to the status of
donetsk and luhansk
well let's bring our guests into the
show now we have joining us from moscow
in russia pavel fogenhauer he's a
defense and military analyst with novaya
gazetta
in brussels theresa fallon is director
at the center for russia europe asia
studies and in kiev peter zelmayev he's
executive director at the eurasia
democracy initiative welcome to you all
let me start then with peter is this a
prelude to a wider invasion what's the
view from kiev
well it seems that vladimir putin has
prepared the ground for that uh with his
decision to recognize these so-called
people's republics of luhansk and
donetsk and the union essentially
unilateral
abrogation of the minsk agreement
he has uh untied his hands uh the you
know the puppet states now are claiming
that they want to
uh
to have the rest of the territory which
is still under ukrainian control and
that is like two-thirds
still unoccupied by uh putin's henchmen
that means uh you know russia through
its puppet states has much further
uh into ukraine's territory to go and
vladimir putin uh is uh if not planning
to
do that he has definitely uh made it
very possible for himself in the next
few days uh to uh try to um reconquer
that territory and still you know retain
plausible
as he thinks denied that he is involved
like what he did with crimeans the
so-called green man um this would be a
sort of uh you know help of solidarity a
kind of uh brotherly assistance to
the you know brotherly stateless of
luhansk donetsk he could even try to
involve other nations uh from the former
soviet republics who are members of the
collective uh security uh treaty
organization to make it look like an
international uh peace action by uh
continuing to claim that russia i'm
sorry ukraine is the one that has been
uh attacking the donbass this is
interesting you mentioned there the
green men pavel in moscow russia has
long been accused of having its soldiers
in donetsk and lugansk the so-called
little uh the so-called green men
you know there without official insignia
does it make a huge difference now that
russia
is recognizing and officially announcing
that it's putting troops there
oh yes i mean the first time the green
man appeared that was in crimea because
first russia was saying that these are
local people kind of
rebelling against the
government or the non-government in kef
then of course it was said officially
that these are russian troops
and russia has never up to now
acknowledged that there are russian
servicemen in the the donbass though
they were said that these are maybe
volunteers who took
a recess from active service and went
there as volunteers but now we have a
totally different situation this would
be russian officials
soldiers though the west reports coming
uh
in moscow are that russia will not right
now move its troops into bennett's
gulgansk though there are other reports
that there has doing it but anyways if
the fighting on the line of control uh
continues even small skirmishes
and if it gets in the russian forces get
involved actually legally and if there's
going to be reports in the russian state
tv about rush young russian soldiers
being killed by or wounded by ukrainians
that's already a pre-route for a direct
uh ukrainian-russian war
that can escalate
into an all-out russia ukrainian war
which can further actually escalate into
the european wards it's a very slippery
scope we are right now on and of course
our uh putin has also said yesterday
that ukraine will become nato member no
matter what the western powers right now
say
and
and so that's also kind of mean and the
sanctions will be imposed anyway so he
was actually digging his heels in and
saying that russia will take action and
now it's clear that how it might happen
so of course maybe that's not happening
now and right and there's going to be a
ceasefire again imposed in the donbass
but we'll have to see what's happening
in the next several days i wonder if
we're already getting a hint of what you
were talking about pavel let me take
this point to teresa was it telling when
we heard the russian president
warn that any further aggression as he
put it from kiev will cause bloodshed
bloodshed which kiev will be responsible
for is that
perhaps an indication of the sort of
scenario pavel was just talking about
russian casualties could lead to a
bigger
you know wider invasion
yes it is a very serious situation that
we're in the speech yesterday by
president putin the 65-minute long
diatribe has been
many analysts have said it's a
declaration of war and so we've seen the
the biden administration trying to
identify these false flag activities for
the last few days and it seemed that
putin just decided to go ahead with this
even though
the idea of five ukrainian soldiers
passing into russia
most people had said that that was just
a false flag and an excuse for russia to
take these actions so i think that they
are trying to frame it they're preparing
the the russian public for a possible
war possible people coming home in body
bags and as we know that as they
evacuate women and children from the
region the men are staying because
they're expected to to fight so i think
that with 190 000 troops surrounding
ukraine i think that
it might be more than just declaring uh
luhansk and donetsk you know sovereign
and the other thing that's a bit unclear
right now is that
how much of that area is it just what's
occupied now by
russian proxies or will it be the entire
region and so i think that the kremlin
is almost deliberately keeping that
unclear because at this point no one
really knows that's the big question
mark over everyone and that will have an
effect on the type of sanctions that
both uh the europeans are willing to
impose and it's interesting to note that
just short
as your presentation noted uh the uk
which is now brexited from the rest of
europe is trying to lead the charge here
and they've already announced sanctions
but the first uh set of sanctions on
five banks and three uh russian entity
people so i think that they're trying to
lead the charge and the europeans may be
a bit divided on this but we've also
seen a clear message from german
chancellor schultz that nordstrom 2 will
be suspended the russian gas pipeline to
germany all right there's a lot for us
to pick up especially when it comes on
sanctions but before we go down there i
want to ask
peter in kiev
peter i can see you're angling to get in
let me uh allow you to get in with a
comment before i pose a question to you
then
well yeah i just wanted to say uh you
know as far as the the sanctions i mean
we will talk it more in depth about it i
did want to mention that it's very
notable that the german chancellor
finally who up till now was reluctant to
even name the you know and allude to
nordstrom 2 by uh by name uh finally uh
put his you know foot where his mouth
was and stated you know unambiguously
that north stream 2 has been halted this
is very important uh this is a troubling
development for vitamin putin europe uh
if europe decides to act as a unified
kind of western front against vladimir
putin it's going to make it much more
complicated it's a sort of a game of
chicken that vladimir putin is involved
in where the both sides are are trying
to see who swerves first as they're
careening
down the highway towards each other all
right let me take then this point to
pavel in in moscow putin could have done
this step a long time ago months ago
perhaps even years ago
is this really
part of a a careful strategy on the part
of the russian president to slowly turn
the heat up on the west because his his
goal is to get his demands met
more than
getting himself embroiled in a wider
invasion of ukraine what do you think
pavel
well it's not really slow the
events began happening
last december and they are developing
very swiftly uh towards a possible world
war actually isn't it is not slower than
if we take the what happened with crimea
that was quite quick when when putin
decides he wants to go in and take his
territory you know people literally woke
up and their russia was there wasn't
this months of a standoff in demands and
meetings and negotiations and back and
forth was there
well i mean because right now we're not
of course in a different situation than
then and um
the russia why right now russia has put
the demands so drastically for and and
is kind of demanding that give us what
we
want or will take it by force
uh again that's not totally clear why
right now putin believes that he so is
so emboldened
uh he doesn't have the unequivocal
support of the russian population people
were scared of a possible war
he doesn't even have the unequivocal
support of the entire russian elite
enough his actually people in the
kremlin and his
administration fully many have
apprehensions on what's right now
happening but apparently right now putin
believes that he is in the position to
put demands that maybe it's because of
these new hypersonic weapons that russia
has been developing and he believes that
it gives russia the upper hand and that
russia now is militarily stronger for
the time being and should really use
this opportunity
to push the west and the united states
away from its borders secure a kind of
buffers a big buffer zone between itself
and the west and nato
again i we don't know for sure but it
looks like that all right let me bring
teresa in teresa
given that does diplomacy still have a
chance
i mean we always must try for diplomacy
but we've seen this
diplomats and world leaders beating a
path to the kremlin's door and pretty
much
nothing was happening i mean even uh
wallace of the uk said it had a whiff of
munich about it because there was never
any de-escalation that was kind of what
was needed for continued dialogue so
the russians pretended to de-escalate
while continuing to escalate and having
all of these discussions we saw
president macron pretty much humiliated
because after five hours of discussions
with putin putin said it was a form of
torture having to talk to macron for so
long but let me foreign let me present
you of course the russian narrative on
this and they would say that's because
the west has been wasting time in these
negotiations and not observing as they
see it russia's security demands and
concerns are not addressing them
well they had the meeting at nato which
was the first time in two years that
they met
at that level and i think
the way that uh putin submitted his
demands was not a way of having dialogue
he said sign this this is what we want
we want this to be a treaty so there was
no discussion really there was no
dialogue it was like take it or leave it
and i think that
there were some off-ramps offered to
putin for example discussions on troop
placement uh
missile placement and
possibly you know nuclear
weapons discussions once again to to
reanimate those uh discussions so i
think that they did try to offer them
off ramps but
putin has not accepted that at all and i
think that uh instead of getting less
nato
the kremlin's getting more nato we're
seeing sweden and finland watching this
very closely and as we know they are
neutral countries but
maybe if you're not a member of nato
this is what will happen to you all
right let me bring in uh once again
peter
the message from kiev has been very
clear in the last few days that they
wanted stronger sanctions and they
wanted them now
what do you think
the analysis will be in kiev of the
sanctions which have been imposed so far
are they enough well once again i think
the signal from germany is kind of
unexpected because germany germany has
been considered the the odd man out as
far as the coordinated western policy uh
putin has been banking on the support of
germany as justland casters those one
tried to understand and sympathize with
russia so once again this probably has
thrown a monkey wrench into vladimir
putin's calculations uh as far as joe
biden's announced sanctions against the
state let's uh um you know well this is
part of his strategy to still use them
as a potential you know for potential
kind of leverage with russians but they
understand that uh you know they don't
even reach the level of symbolism that
is required i mean these republics are
already isolated
uh quasi entities they don't trade with
anyone these sanctions don't go far they
don't buy it there's a an understandable
kind of uh you know upset that ukraine
has a feeling over it but it ain't over
till it's over and uh biden has
announced that more
uh sanctions are to come so ukrainians
are you know uh waiting to see but let
me just return to the point uh uh
earlier about uh nato expansion i just
cannot uh avoid commenting on it uh once
again just to make it clear uh the nato
expansion
has been a red herring of vladimir putin
all along i don't think he's concerned
with ukraine joining nato he knows it's
not gonna happen anytime soon but what
he's concerned about is trying to
recreate a form of soviet union um in a
different shape or form uh he considers
uh the loss of ukraine a personal
tragedy he wants uh to ukraine to follow
the kind of the trajectory of belarus
next door belarus has essentially over
the last year become a protectorate of
russia under military occupation and
that's exactly what vladimir putin is
trying to achieve in ukraine he wants to
dominate it and he made it clear last
actually yesterday in his speech he does
not even recognize ukraine as a
legitimate state he said it as early as
20 years ago in his meeting with george
w bush he said george ukraine ain't even
a country and we're seeing 20 years
later we're seeing a very direct kind of
uh you know
there's more for us to pick apart when
it comes to go there i want to bring in
once again pavel
pavel the sanctions are still coming in
take us through what we know about them
so far what sanctions are in place and
what sort of impact do you think moscow
will
will deem them to have
well i've seen from moscow these the
sanctions already announced after the
recognition of the sovereignty of those
rather mild
the russian uh stock exchange rebounds
when they were announced and especially
that need their
big russian banks like alpha banks bear
bank uh but the bank are not included
and there's fears that they will be
included immediately uh so the and of
course uh personal uh uh pinpoint
sanctions are not russia's use to them
more or less so these are not yet that
serious sanctions at all
and
the
former president and now putin's deputy
in the security council meet your
medvedev saying ah they're going to fret
they're going to yell and then they're
going to come to us and negotiate so we
just have to sit it out
the same as after we invaded
georgia and uh that recognize the
sovereignty of asia and abkhazia so
right now i don't think that the
announced actions are very much a kind
of serious considered as a serious
deterrent all right there won't be too
worried teresa talking about putin's
latest speech is it something of a
turning point up until now we were
hearing the message from putin and from
the foreign minister that hey we don't
want to invade there is no invasion this
is all hysteria and in the latest speech
it sounded like putin was questioning
the very right of ukraine to exist as an
independent country
yes i think it is extremely worrying
this message we're not seeing
upholding as u.n states sovereignty
issues are being
he's not invading because it's not a
sovereign country that's his narrative
and that uh many historians for example
tim snyder of yale university says that
this is putin's fantasy from a thousand
years ago fairy tale so the fact that
he is pretending it is not a country and
therefore can be absorbed by russia i
think is an extremely worrying narrative
and this is to to kind of prep the the
russian population
about this they're kind of reabsorbing
their cousins but i think that um
they what many analysts have stated that
they will that they will want to have
regime change they just need a
leadership that will be more pro russia
let me play devil's advocate again if
you permit me to raise her and present
the perspective that you know on the
other side would argue that this is
exactly what all world powers have done
including the us with countries like
cuba in their backyard that they want
their spheres of influences
well of course they're
it's hard to tell people in 2022 you can
only be a buffer state and that's what
russia wants they want ukraine to be one
giant buffer state and i think that uh
it is clear that there will be no boots
put on the ground by any western power
in in in ukraine that has been made
absolutely clear and i think that putin
has made his calculations that they have
proved weatherproof themselves for the
last seven years with fortress russia
this idea of becoming less dependent on
the west uh having other financial
instruments they only use sixteen
percent of their exchanges are in
dollars now so that's a big decline from
40 several years ago so i think that
they have been working and preparing on
this and let's not forget the big
difference between now and what happened
in crimea back in 2014 is that they have
the tasted support of beijing we saw
putin go to uh beijing signed this
agreement uh with president xi and so
they have this understanding that even
from beijing all right i'm afraid we are
running out of time we're going to have
to leave it there it's been a great
discussion let's thank our guests
pavel falgenhauer theresa fallon and
peter zalmayev
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again any time by visiting
our website aljazeera.com
for further discussion head over to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there is at aj inside story
from me sami zaydan and the whole team
here for now it's goodbye
[Music]